hey I'm Scott Cooper the writer and the
director of the pale blue eye and this
is Harry melling I play Edgar Allan Poe
in the pale blue eye and we're going to
dissect a scene for you
[Music]
I am pleased to report I have
successfully decoded your message
this of course is one of the most
important scenes in the picture I think
up to this point we we get a strong
sense that Augustus Landor is amused by
you but he also thinks that you have a
keen sense of observation
observational skills that might make you
a an interesting and wonderful detective
yes yes and he wants you to to help
decode a message that was found crumpled
in the rigor mortised hand of a Cadet
who was found hanged in the heart
removed from his chest handwritten it is
of a personal nature fry headed with him
at the time of his death from that he
may presume it was sufficient to draw
whom from his barracks on the night in
question
as the rest of the message was torn from
his hand we may presume that the note in
some way identify its center now the use
of rather primitive black capitals would
also indicate that the sender wished to
disguise his identity an invitation of
thoughts or might be more accurately
call it a trap
it's um a real introduction to Poe and
and his ability to to deduce but also to
entertain us
but also for us to uh have an
understanding of of the way in which his
poetic and romantic musings
uh help build his character and that was
a wonderful challenge because it allowed
him to be Charming allowed him to be
funny it allowed him to be the the both
the smartest person in the room but also
the silliest and that was a wonderful
thing to play with as an actor because
uh
he was so contradictory and and
um and Rich and this I'd say is the
first challenge that Lando I think it is
the first challenge that land or gives
to Poe and so I think he's very keen to
impress I mean he's Keen to impress
Lando from the off but with this is a
real opportunity to really show his
worth and his intellect now with that in
mind oh man huh let's concentrate our
labors on the third line which we know
for a fact is complete B but be what
something that begins with air
little
lucky
no
no now the Jabs with the invitation be
lost
no no two ungainly a construction Oh
Heaven fatler or frazz attendance was
desired at a particular time and place
there is but one word
linked B
conflict
and as we scan the third line the first
word becomes almost insultingly simple
to deduce don't so don't be
when I first read the script I am
I I found it a fantastic who'd done it
the Thriller element that runs through
it was was I thought just incredibly
exciting
but putting that against a landscape
that was so rich and detailed that was
what truly got me really excited and
then putting this Edgar and po character
in the middle of it and and working out
who is this man who is the man before
um the iconic sort of Darker Edgar Allan
Poe that we we think we all know and all
those things working in tandem was I
mean
it was a gift for an actor really look
closely Mr Lindor we did not Journey far
for a suitable candidate ifra is going
to a predetermined location he was from
the perspective of the writer coming so
come Mr Fry now with that in place it is
the heart of Simplicity to deduce the
next word can it be any other then soon
we insert the word
don't be late come soon and there you
have it the solution to our petite and
it may respectfully submit it
first grade work I thank you did you
feel any sort of uh pressure a as
playing Edgar Allan Poe and also as your
first day as a performer on the film
well yeah I think I pressure maybe is
not the right word I just knew that I
had to give land or enough reasons to
fall in love with poem you know his
ambition as a as a writer all of that
stuff had to be there and I just knew
that
fun you should be smart but also he
should be awkward he should be foolish
all those things should really live in
this scene
um and yes there's a there's a lot to to
achieve in terms of that range that you
wrote but uh it was really just taking
it Moment by Moment by moment and just
seeing what the day revealed that for
the first day working with Christian I I
soon realized he's one of the most
generous of actors and
and just us being in that room we felt
very focused it felt very free and all
the things you really need from a set in
order to try and um be somewhere that
you need to be when you when you do a
scene like this just one thing did you
have any luck with the first two lines
well I was forced to declare them a loss
are you a good speller oh Flawless judge
so by no less an authority than the
Reverend John Brands be of stoke
Newington so I I take it that
you've never done what so many have
stew
spell
similar sounding words
for example
there there and there
he come solar system an invitation and
they may be there of course we still
don't know where to meet
do we
something with Ng
trailing behind
The Landing
and mother at the cold by the land
excellent
so I'll be at the Cove by The Landing
meet me there and say 11 pm something of
that sword don't be late come
this scene I remember saying to my
longtime cinematographer Masa Nobu
takinagi I want it to feel like it was
lit by a Dutch Master so if you imagine
that it was Rembrandt who came in and
lit this all in Candlelight which would
have been the source of light as well as
fire but that much of it is is in
darkness and in Shadow which really
encapsulates
um Poe's work on a thematic level the
things Massa was doing with the light
was just extraordinary like I think I
came up to you and said what what how
are they how's he doing that how's he
achieving that and he's like it's just
Delight it's just a natural light and I
thought wow that's amazing does this
suggest anything to you
profoundly meet a fellow Conde to The
Landing
when you can meet him anywhere
because it's not a Cadet
but a woman hmm
you knew the solution all along Mr
Lindor I had an idea directorily for me
I wanted the camera to be as invisible
as possible to shoot very classically so
that I I have the two of you in the
frame but then it's we as we get much
closer to you and you you sit into this
that it's really about bringing the two
of you closer together because this is
the central relationship in the film
well it is is indeed a woman we seek
I believe I may be credited with a
certain of her
the morning after the Roy Friday's death
before I knew anything for the past
I walk
and began speaking the open lands of a
poem
learns that speak of a mysterious woman
in profound distress
then just outside the mess appears the
most
creature I've ever had the pleasure of
laying and in this particular moment
when you sit down and discuss with
Landor that you were awakened yes and
you were compelled to write and you have
a vision of someone that turns out to be
someone you fall in love with
uh Leah Marquis played by the wonderful
Lucy Boynton that speaks to Poe being
haunted by the death of his mother
Poe being
transfixed with where life ends and
death begins
and this notion of Leah and Leonor
someone that he wrote about quite often
absolutely his Muse yes yes
[Music]
I haven't defended
but why do you believe that this poem or
young women are connected with Mr Fry
the air of concealed of violence
speakable duress
an unknown woman
you could have woken anyone in the
written this
but I didn't ride
he was dictated dictated
by you
my mother
she's dead
near you 20 years
beautiful well the scene turned out
better than I could have ever hoped when
I was writing it not an easy scene to
write uh at the moment I had Christian
of course in mind to play this part and
then I was reminded as I was writing it
of The Ballad of Buster Scruggs in your
performance is the limbless performer
and I thought there was no one who can
bring Poe to life better than Harry
melling and and as a director it was
really about let's get out of the way
and let two performers at the top of
their game do what they do best and I
think you beautifully captured I think
this scene certainly
made that a reality so thank you man oh
man thanks so much love